hallo mein name ist wo kann ich dann
überhaupt nicht mal also wenn ihr kunst
sehen wollt dann verpisst euch am besten
ein das sollte jetzt nicht so wirklich
vielleicht hier ein bisschen kann ich
nicht kann wirklich nicht mal so geht
einfach hier hat mir wieder unter den
hashtag mal viele bilder geschickt unter
anderem auch dass hiervon von haben wir
mal den jetzt mal
der leyen ist natürlich sonst mal so ein
richtiger kleiner cutie beauty bei auf
diesem bild dieter allerdings ein
bisschen ja so ein bisschen komisch
außerdem habe ich eben das und blaues
auge der mahltig vollidiot dann kriegt
er hier schön das video days bändchen
noch mal so schön gemalt dann kriegt man
da hinten jetzt noch schön dass heino
wieso steht eigentlich kein konkreter
drauf meint was soll das freunde es geht
ran an die konturen beziehungsweise an
die etwas anderen sachen hier kommen
hier kriegt jeder was rum
damit man sieht wo genau dafür tun die
hier läuft hier genau hier geht der plan
hier so ein komischer streifen dann
haben wir hier noch irgendwie was ich
weiß was mal ich denn hier schon die
dafür eine scheiße jetzt kommt wieder
die master chiefs aufgabe alter
irgendwie hinkriegen dass man die
konturen richtig hinbekommt also erstmal
um die herum damit man sieht für seine
wunderhübsche wahrscheinlich gang oder
löwen trug erkenne hier schon noch die
haare so ein bisschen reinkommt sowie
sketche mir ein bisschen sorgen den
seiten noch ein paar haare
denn hier im forum hier geht das gesicht
noch lange hier hier hier hier um das
auge herum dass die augen kann ich
definitiv nicht so lassen luca viele
sagen ja immer noch das ist ein liegt
einfach daran weil ich mir keine mühe
gehen kam jessica ich kann nicht
zeichnen aber dieses bild oder witz ist
bisher ist es nicht so kacke oder hier
so sieht's aus als wir machen jetzt erst
mal hier bei dem oberen bild die
deckkraft wieder hoch damit wir sehen ok
sosa leyen vor dem wild aus und jetzt
schauen uns an wie ich den laien gemalt
habe es geht klar oder
also ich hätte er kann tatsächlich finde
es wunderschön
also jetzt ohne witz wenn man das bild
hier kennt das bild dann weiß man dass
das hier laien ist also das ist mit
abstand das beste bild was ich je getan
wahrscheinlich denken jetzt leute die
noch nie die serie gesehen haben
wie das ist das beste was der hier
gezeichnet hat der kann ja gar nicht
zeichnen
ja das stimmt aber laien und mein gott
ist doch letztlich so scheiße oder also
jetzt ohne spaß hey leyen leyen tina was
ist das denn für eine scheiße twitter
das herz von meinen mal künsten
aber ich trotzdem wirst du mit alter ist
das wundervoll einfach ein unfassbar
tolles bild wie sophia ich hab vergessen
sein product placement an zumal in
diesem café latte
ach du scheiße wunderschön luca xd naja
kommt dass in photoshop mal wären wir
machen weiter mit photoshop nicht mit
twitter apropos twitter habe ich
übrigens auch noch eine idee was ich da
eventuell bald eine serie machen könnte
die geht es doch nicht auf youtube aber
ich sag's nicht weil immer wenn ich
etwas sage mache das dann plötzlich
irgendwelche andere youtuber das nächste
bild ist ein bild wo ich nicht ganz
genau weiß was dort passiert ist und
zwar ist es baby oder wer ist das und
was hat die da im mund alter das sieht
auf jeden fall nicht so aus als wäre
auch dem die hat davon auch was in den
haaren ich will nicht wissen was das ist
denn ich bin nur hier um sie zu
verschönern und ich denke dass das werde
ich jetzt einfach mal machen
das sehe ich ja jetzt erst noch ihre
beiden hände um das aufzufangen was geht
ab baby bezüglich baby gab seinerzeit
aus ein paar sachen in den medien ja fan
wartet drei tage vorm hotel und baby
schreibt einfach süß
das ist falsch mit der welt wollen wenn
ich mal irgendwo im urlaub in und ihr
wartet bei mir vor der tür dann würde
ich euch vors gesicht packen und nicht
schreiben dass das süße ist also ich
würde euch liebevoll vors gesicht kacken
mit dem eine kacke richtung nach engels
ich halte meine schnauze ja was hat denn
die hier für kleine augen wie soll ich
das denn hinkriegen das sieht aus wie
solche chinesen augen jetzt acht nicht
dass ich nicht zeichnen kann sondern es
sieht nicht so aus wie soll ich das okay
das war vielleicht ein bisschen zu krass
gesagt lange strich
ok baby letztes allerdings der der da
irgendwie aus dem mund geflossen wie
wichtig wissen wenn du dir das video
siehst ich will nicht dein video schauen
wo das passiert ist weil ich der böse
gedanken habe und ich weiß auf welcher
plattform ich da schauen soll aber die
sache mir mal bitte was du da gemacht
hast oder weiß dass einer von uns nicht
negativ wissen okay ich denke wir sind
mehr oder weniger fertig also das hier
ist das originalbild von bdi vor ihrem
tollen regal wo sie übrigens ich habe
nichts gegen biene nicht dass ihr
irgendwie wieder gerüchte die welt
gesetzt werden dass ich hier mit die
mieten die mit über die serie irgendwie
jedem youtuber eins auswischen
ich hab nichts gegen ganzen youtube ich
kenne die meisten nicht mehr persönlich
aber das was ich hier von den sehe denke
ich einfach nur der content von dem der
ist doch alter egal wir schauen uns
jetzt auf jeden fall mal das
originalbild an und jetzt schauen wir
uns mal das bild das ich von baby gemalt
habe und zwar sdl eigentlich ganz gut
ich habe die augen vergessen sind die
vögel oder jetzt hat sie weiße augen
aber egal fast zum baby wird was das
hält sich hiervon ich hab dich
gezeichnet und ach du heilige scheiße
das sieht einfach aus wie ein kribbeln
aber baby findet bestimmt süß dass ich
sie gezeichnet habe weil ich habe auch
drei tage dafür
ok ich würde mich gar nicht meine
unterschrift darunter zu setzen weil ich
einfach
so ein bisschen angst hab das dann im
management kommt mich umbringt in
sondern nacht und nebel aktion
aber mein gott egal so freude das ist
das bild nummer zwei wir haben baby
gemalt und ja auf welchem bild findet
ihr sie schöne bild nummer drei ist von
einem youtuber der extrem hübsch
aussieht und zwar ist es den du kleiner
es behinderte die dena hat irgendwie
seine übels blasse haut auf diesem foto
zumindest aber ich habe das irgendwie
glaube ich viel zu brauchen gemacht sah
mein gott ich bin locker nicht die
kassen in der tat
bisher würde ich eher sagen dass ich
hier atze schröder mal und nicht denen
die haare sehen sondern so ein bisschen
glück haben wenn mein kommentar stil in
diesem video zeigt einfach wieder dass
es acht uhr morgens ist ich will mir
immer mal so ein bisschen mehr mühe
geben bei den sachen aber dann sehe ich
immer schon in der roder teil dass wir
jetzt schon alles klar 43 minuten nice
luca viel spaß beim schneiden so hier
noch schön die szene so ein bisschen
weiß machen und dann nehmen wir noch
diese pinkl dings um ihm die lippe so
ein bisschen anzudeuten und dann haben
wir es auch eigentlich jeden moment
schon fertig und zwar mache ich das
jetzt eben noch schnell den mond so das
heißt die augen habe ich mal wieder
vergessen ich hätte dafür eine
augenfarbe hat der grün oder irgendwie
so ich weiß gar nicht genau so manchmal
einfach grün und dann packen wir noch
eine schwarze pupille eben rein so also
freunde hier das originalbild bisschen
heller hier dena im original wundervoll
also muss wirklich sagen denke mir wird
aber definitiv [ __ ] him und dann schauen
wir uns jetzt mal der meine zeit ist
ähnelt er angela merkel in verbindung
mit einem stein das beschreibt ist
eigentlich relativ genau ich habe es
irgendwie somit den pupillen
wir werden irgendwie nicht schaden den
mund hätte ich vielleicht ein bisschen
kommen den mund - ein bisschen schwarz
die damit man sieht dass das ganze ein
bisschen tiefer rein geht der horror
so sieht es aus als hätte er in die
schwarze zähne oder so aber mein gott
das ist den meine lieben freunde obwohl
man ihn hier auch nicht mehr richtig
erkennen kann jetzt alle diener fan
girls der sieht viel besser aus
luca du kannst gar nicht zeichnen schön
kontrakte auf seine wundervolle
haarpracht geschrieben so sieht es ist
einfach ist es ich entschuldige mich für
dieses bild de na ja meine lieben
freunde das war's dann auch schon mit
dieser heutigen folge bei photoshop
bearbeiten wenn es euch gefallen hat
will ich mich definitiv bei den
bewertungen freuen weil ich jetzt in der
rother 2 47 minuten bin und definitiv an
dem video drei stunden schneiden werde
wenn ihr mehr davon wollt dann steckt
euch doch ein kopf in den mülleimer
tschüss